God college tuition I've got two small
children and figuring that all out and
the fact that when they're getting there
it's just going to be you know half a
million dollars a year slightly
frightens me I think that that that
keeps certainly keeps my husband up a
little bit and as a result of that I
stay awake I want to be able to be
involved in fashion for a very long time
I love to work fashion is not
necessarily an industry that allows age
it's about youth and flash in the pan
and things that change all the time so I
think I worry a bit about continuing in
a mini full way my career going forward
and and and having having some
importance to my existence because I
don't want to not work i love it and i'm
a better more i think saner and happier
person because i do work and need to do
that in my life so yeah college tuition
is probably the kind of long yeah sort
of long-term panics i have which our
college tuition and how do you morph and
still stay viable in an industry that
does not necessarily like age in the way
some you know politics or law or other
things actually you know embraces that
in fashion does not so I worry about how
to be smart about going forward and
getting older